but if you care to go when there's an
odd number of terms you quite quickly
discover actually it turns out to be
fine right having an odd number two
doesn't break things at all for instance
if we wait with the same series we had
before the odd numbers and if I hand it
in 97 there are 49 times you now the
reason why it seems kinda intuitive is
because if we put n which is 49 at the
front right you've got 49 on two-thirds
24 and a half right and you got to
multiply that by something so it looks
like we've got a fraction that's been
introduced into our son even though all
the things you're adding up our whole
numbers so how come why we have a
fraction out the front one let's think
about this think about what's actually
in here right - a + d know they ought to
read whatever a was we can start at 1 5
or 15 or 20 - 2 a will be an even number
right because it's it's 2 times
something else a mix of you and then
when you have a look at this part here
and minus 1 well we said the whole
problem of this was the end was odd
right but if ends odd then n minus 1
will be even right so this is gonna be
an even number this will also be an even
number okay so seeing is within them and
even the Samba to do the numbers is also
even and so this divided by 2 just
simply it does it doesn't cause us any
fractions because what's in here will
always be times 2 of something that's
why it this still works it still checks
out ok one last thing to finish yourself
leave me at stand on that exercise I'll
show you what I want you to do so far
we've been starting from I see
secrets that we do is admit and then we
start doing you order stuff on it but
often what you'll get asked to show is
you have a series or a sequence we want
you to prove that's okay how we go about
doing this it's not quite like a
geometry proof what's the definition of
that and advocacy puts it's that there's
that common difference right so what
would concerts do the proof what would
make it um what would satisfy you just
say yes this secrets has to be
arithmetic or we're looking for we want
every turn every turn - the previous one
in other words the difference that's the
difference between each successive term
we want it to be equal to a constant
right that's a lot so in fact this is
this is pretty simple so for instance if
we gave you this sequence up here what
you would have to do is show well 10 to
1 is equal to 2 right in this case
because what they have what they've
given us is the examples on the church
we're gonna do this a few times because
it's not nice enough just to have one
right if alternatively they defined the
sequence for you in terms of its ends
terms
this is the odd number sequence right so
we are intending n times 2 n minus 1
okay so how can I show you sneak out
work well I say that's team N 1 T of n
minus 1 equal to we're just every way
you've seen n just like a function you
replace with n minus 1 yeah actually
makes sense it's this term minus 2 right
that's we went backwards 1 so now when I
take the difference cancel cancel minus
1 plus 3 as well that's good I got it
right because the common difference is 2
does that make sense so you can either
go this route if they just give you a
series of terms we've got an action show
for the terms that you've got or if they
give you a definition for the nth term
in terms of n this is the way you go
about it you'd find out what is the n
minus 1 term algebraically and then take
the difference you mean you mean do this
if I if you got this you know well in a
sense if I've got this and what I want
to show is this the easiest way the most
direct path is souring on this piece now
I just need the space